so our next speaker is mr ellia brodsky
mr brodsky is one of the co-founders and
ceo of pine biotech
he has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams
mr brodsky oversees the research
projects and manages the development of
the prototype preparation of relevant
data projects and implementation of the
system for the needs of the students and
teachers that the project is designed
for
so please join me in welcoming mr ellia
brodsky
thank you very much again uh
congratulations
to everyone and it's really exciting to
see how all of this actually connects
and i'm really pleased to be a part of
this symposium today
and what i want to share with you today
is actually how we're going to continue
and expand the omics logistics program
so what we saw
in the past couple of days um are the
multiple directions that bioinformatics
can play a role from precision medicine
to
pharmaceutical companies biotechnology
companies astrobiology
origins of life right it's not really a
domain specific discipline but it
empowers researchers in many different
directions and so what i want to talk to
you about today is uh first how did we
establish this program in the first
place where it's going and specifically
focus on one aspect
which is the program that we're
developing together with the national
association of idea principal
investigators
so the national association of idea
principal investigators is a
network of idea-funded
pis
uh idea program is an nih specific
program designed to elevate biomedical
research and so what
is common
across all of these different states
that you see on the map
is that they don't receive as much
funding as some of the hubs
but i think that actually speaks to a
general problem that is also beyond the
united states
unfortunately
the money is not equally distributed
across all institutions
and so i think in the u.s it's exciting
to see how special allocation of funding
is making
uh high level uh research possible in
these states but if you go to um you
know we're located in new orleans and
louisiana right here
and and if you kind of compare how
things are done here
you might see a lot of differences
between let's say what's happening
in boston massachusetts san diego or san
francisco and what's happening here
and
similar to what you know others
experience around the world
there is a challenge to attract talent
and there's a challenge to
make this talent work together focusing
on local problems
and accelerating research that addresses
local issues and that is what this
program is specifically designed to do
the funding the idea funding is really
designed to help establish
sequencing centers cores
really
enabling technologies so that other
researchers that are striving to pursue
advanced topics in different areas of
research especially biomedical research
can be successful and across all of
these states there is a need in
bioinformatics
so um over the course of the past just
several months we've started a pilot
with the national idea uh national
association of idea principal
investigators to design
a resource and implement uh programs to
support training in biology as a data
science so i'll briefly talk about omics
logic
for anyone who's here and who's not
heard about it previously
so omixlogic is a portal designed to
kind of combine multiple things that we
saw today
and it starts from a portal that you can
find on this link learn
omixlogic.com
you can register for free and
you
become a part of the community once you
register it's a free registration you
get access to not only free resources
but importantly networks that we're
building and i think a network that you
have seen today that combines experts
students faculty
researchers and others
and importantly what this portal allows
us to do is it allows us to combine
the learning and the research
around a personal profile so in the
personal profile we've designed elements
like sharing about your background
connecting your social media tracking
your progress of learning uh badges for
different programs that you complete and
it allows the faculty to see how the
progress in your learning matches with
the objectives of whatever the program
uh pursues so importantly we've designed
a
process of certification that actually
allows us to make sure that people when
they become interested in a particular
area of research are actually ready and
prepared and informed to apply
bioinformatics in a meaningful way
and so after you receive this basic
certification then the next step is to
make sure that your profile is complete
and you're able to pursue your research
topic your idea so some of the projects
that we saw yesterday in the poster
presentation uh today we had uh dr
emantoria and uh jesse so they were a
part of the research fellowship and
actually many many more students
participate in this process every
semester
attempting to complete
novel independent or group projects
using publicly available data and so
we've built this format because we think
that you know beyond certification and
kind of basic skills really the
validation that you know something is
when you can apply it to something of
your own
and because bioinformatics is such a
diverse and dynamic field because
natural interests are so different we
cannot design programs around everything
and so we're opening it up for anyone
who would like to pursue a project to
really be able to do that in a
reproducible way
so once that is done
uh we
are actually
going to
do a biannual events like this one to
bring the community together select the
most promising projects and uh one of
the things that we would like to do is
actually turn those projects into
opportunities for others to learn so
it's not just a way to learn and develop
your own research it's also a way to
contribute and share what you have done
with the broader network and the
community
beyond this
with this expanding library and i want
to pause here by the way and say that uh
one of our objectives in the next few
months is to open this platform to other
contributors and we've started working
with several programs around the nippy
uh southeastern region
to start working on new materials to add
to the library that we've developed so
far
and this is going to be around several
different basic topics like genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics or
epigenomics
data science and a general free course
that we're going to make available for
anyone to kind of take and use as they
need
called introduction to bioinformatics
or bytes and molecules
and so um that is really uh one aspect
that i wanted to highlight today
is that
um you know one of our missions as a
company is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
make it easier to participate in make it
easier to
apply practically
and make it easier for someone who does
not have any technical background
to really benefit from it as soon as
possible so in a faster
way to kind of appreciate the role and
the meaning of bioinformatics
and so for that we are creating this
free resource anyone can use it
anyone can
you know as a faculty use it as a
resource for teaching
and in fact we're going to start a
partner program that will allow
for the more advanced topics to follow
after this brief uh and maybe optional
introduction
and one of the things that we're going
to include in this package is not just
the the basic modules like introduction
to bioinformatics or bytes and molecules
or getting started with bioinformatics
in r and python but it importantly uh
provide a view of these many different
topics like we heard in the past couple
of days
uh how is bioinformatics used in
precision medicine
how is bioinformatics used in
astrobiology how is bioinformatics used
in pharmaceutical companies
drug discovery you know all of these
topics they are
the things that drive bioinformatics
forward right so bioinformatics i think
is not driven by
uh just computational and algorithmic
innovation but primarily it is driven by
people that understand the data
challenges that these domains bring
and so another part of what we um are
really passionate about as a company is
not just the diversity of bioinformatics
applications but also how
these bioinformatics methods and tools
are used by experts
so
obviously it is great when we can have
speakers like her today and yesterday
come and present a topic that they have
been studying for decades
but i think it's equally important to
appreciate that
even these presentations are based on a
hypothesis that has been addressed in
some way with evidence
but also reviewed by peers by the
broader community and so that's why the
key uh we believe
is to focus on publications so these
peer-reviewed publications that we can
review and extract uh kind of the
methodology
used by experts including data that was
submitted by them and made publicly
available is the foundation for these
courses and projects that we develop on
this portal
so the portal really provides six basic
courses uh that anyone can uh take and
and kind of we standardize and make sure
that we improve uh the content of these
courses that include introduction to
bioinformatics genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and an
introduction into data science
and on top of the basic level we
actually introduced specialization
tracks
and this is how
bioinformatics is used in oncology in
infectious diseases in neuroscience and
in agriculture and i'll talk a little
bit more about some of these upcoming
programs in the next few slides
what's important though is that as a
part of this coursework we have a
package of enabling technologies and
these enabling technologies are designed
to
again lower the barrier for entry
speed up the process
of going from base to more more complex
topics
and be able to identify the best track
that fits your
current stage and your objective in the
future
uh what do i mean by that
a lot of students um
might be pursuing bioinformatics as a
degree but i think an even greater
proportion of students are not directly
interested in bioinformatics and so for
many as we've seen yesterday especially
this interest in bioinformatics is
something that shapes over the years and
so it's not appropriate to dump all the
complexities and kind of the
requirements for coding languages and
statistics right up front in that
process and so
we try to present a variety of paths
that you can pursue
to be able to analyze data and make
discoveries which is the exciting part
and if you choose to do so enough depth
for you to also learn how to develop
your coding skills how to get certified
in different levels of biostatistics or
machine learning and even how to pursue
a more technical resource for cloud
computing for example as we will hear
today as well
so one uh
one important aspect of this is that we
have
code and no code bioinformatics pass and
that means that you can either perform
analysis using the big data analysis
t-biome for platform and we've heard
today about new sections on this
platform it's a dynamic place where
experts contribute new and more
efficient workflows as well as learn
languages like python and r to learn how
to program your own or use existing
packages
and so in a variety of domains i think
that you will see how bioinformaticians
range from biologists that are experts
in using these packages with
understanding of the different settings
with understanding of when to apply what
kind of methodology to answer a specific
question as well as those that go the
technical route and they are able to
engineer novel applications and make
these applications user-friendly and
more efficient for discovery
so with that i think that you know i'll
briefly now speak about several
different programs that are coming up
that you can participate in and we have
our team here with us so if you are
interested in any of these topics as a
faculty or as a student i encourage you
to reach out and at the end we will
share some of the contact information uh
for you to be able to connect with the
right person
so
i think there are exciting many new
ideas and challenges arising in the
field of
gene expression and transcriptomics and
so traditionally we've run a program
called
transcriptomic data analysis or
rna-seq
where we explored bulk rna sequencing
and the volume of bulk rna sequencing
has really been growing over the years
so at the foundational level it was
always important to understand
what is rna sequencing how do these next
generation sequencing technologies work
what are some important methods to
explore and understand this kind of data
design statistical hypothesis testing
techniques and as of recent it's been
really important to also understand the
differences between bulk rna sequencing
and single cell rna sequencing which is
a technology that is becoming more and
more popular and applicable in many
different domains
so we've designed a program
and standardized it to include some
specific aspects that can be taught
either in a short
setting where face-to-face students meet
or supplement that with asynchronous
training exercises that one can complete
both on the omics logic portal and
utilizing the tbionfo platform
so for that we again have a section
section is color coded and explained and
it really covers how you can
analyze data from understanding the
inputs and outputs to the logic behind
the analysis that is coded and explained
in detail why do we have to perform each
one of the individual steps and i think
what we've seen as a result of doing
this program multiple times is how this
approach helps students appreciate how
any kind of analysis can be structured
in a very logical way
after they understand the logic we then
introduce a variety of different types
of projects where they can see the
application of rna sequencing techniques
in oncology in precision medicine
in infectious diseases and epidemiology
with the popularity of single cell
we've seen a uh kind of like an
expectation that this is just exactly
the same as bulk rna sequencing and it
really is not there are a lot of new
methods there are a lot of specific
approaches and a lot of emphasis is put
on downstream interpretation and so as
we have heard today
now we have a full section that kind of
automates and simplifies the downstream
analysis of single cell rnac data using
such packages like silverat
and monocle and importantly it we
provide a step-by-step breakdown of each
one of these logical steps
using exercises that you can perform
independently and i'm excited to say
today that this course is also available
and anyone can find that course on the
onwix logic portal
obviously supplementing the basic
training with project examples is a big
uh
part of what we are trying to do and so
we take these uh publications that have
an impact
in this domain and we break down the
methodology proportion and really
describe how one can analyze such data
and replicate an analysis found in a
publication
with so many different types of omics
data now it's important to not only
understand how to process analyze and
visualize a single type of data but
importantly integrate multinomics data
as well and that's a big part of what we
do on this portal is introduce
multi-omics integration methods that
could be contrasted and compared and
applied in specific domains with a
benchmark so an important part of what
we do in the projects are curated data
sets that one can use to establish an
understanding and really test how well
you apply the methods to get the same
results
as we've seen over the past two years uh
infectious diseases from uh being kind
of a domain that suffered from a lack of
funding
became a domain with exciting new
research and applications that touch the
lives of all of us today and so back in
2000 back in 2020 we launched our
bioinformatics for infectious
diseases program
and we quickly adapted that program to
address the challenges around covet 19
so that not only we're able to
understand pathogens and kind of study
those pathogens using project examples
but also think about applications
and i'll briefly kind of mention a
couple of these applications that we've
seen
resulting from
this program
so as a result of understanding the
methodology and seeing how next
generation sequencing can be used to
study these viruses and and different
types of infectious diseases
we have developed a number of
collaborations around wastewater
sequencing of covet 19 uh monitoring uh
variants of concern and and other types
of uh kind of strange phenotypes that
have been reported in literature
and i think that um you know this kind
of interest in bioinformatics as a
result of the pandemic
of course the pandemic in itself was an
unfortunate event that we're still not
out of but i think it really gave a lot
of popularity
to
terminology methods and even types of
data
that will in the future i think this
generation that went through this uh
pandemic
will uh be so aware and so familiar with
some of the methodology that they
will be able to address uh future
challenges of similar character in a
much more effective way
and so uh we've designed several project
examples a variety of different viral
epidemics and an in-depth training
resource for sars cove 2
where both consensus level and
sub-consensus level analysis could be
performed
not only at the sequence level but
importantly also translating the
sequence level to the immunology and to
the protein protein interaction level so
looking at 3d structures of proteins and
understanding how
they have an effect on vaccine design
and protein protein interaction
and so really at the core of this i
again want to emphasize how significant
it is
that this is available not only for
engineers
uh the t-bone for platform really hides
the complexity of analytical pipelines
and complex algorithms that have been
developed by experts in the field
to make it possible for someone who's a
student
or a biologist or a biochemist to apply
these complex methods and understand how
they are used with practical examples
so methods like processing fasta and
fast q files for multiple sequence of
alignment and comparative analysis of
different sequences
reporting
generating a full report on variants of
concern found in different types of
viral populations
understanding how this data can be
visualized effectively and presented
and also importantly as i mentioned
mapping the mutations that we identify
and understanding how they impact
different aspects of immunology
during this these exercises that we
actually also
look at protein protein interaction
really trying to understand uh the
available resources uh like protein uh
crystallography but also how to connect
the different types of data
and really understand uh the the way
that multiple sources of data could be
used together
now yesterday we spoke with uh dr
sonavasutivan from georgetown university
medical school where she leads a program
on systems medicine and together with
her team and her students we've
developed this program specifically to
introduce a non-engineer to the basics
of data science and machine learning
using r and python
i think that it's a very critical skill
for anyone to learn how to code and i
think that it's
non-trivial for someone who doesn't come
from an engineering background to do so
but
we've seen
how these resources can make it much
easier for someone to learn how to code
quickly and develop a practical sense of
the application of languages like r and
python to address bioinformatics
challenges and so the exercises that we
have available on the the portal include
mapping mutations for metabolism of
different drugs uh really learning how
to code from a syntax perspective from
the perspective of data visualization
uh and the application to many different
types of data such as genomic data
analysis metagenomic data analysis as
well as uh different types of big data
repositories that could be explored and
visualized using such tools
to
you know summarize i think that you know
what we have seen is an explosion of uh
interest in
different domains uh starting from you
know very basic usage of genomics in the
lab
to
such interesting concepts like
spaceonics and uh when i mentioned that
we're opening this platform to other
contributors this is really what uh i am
implying
in different universities in different
labs and in different research fields
experts have dedicated
years if not decades of their life to
identifying important topics and
learning how to
address them in a reproducible and high
quality way
and we
would like to kind of establish a way
for those experts to be able to take
their expertise
and
allow us to design high quality training
materials that could help effectively
many of the people that are
locked out of these domains
to be able to participate by first
learning about these topics and then
knowing how to apply their skills and
their insights and innovation and maybe
creative thinking to address the topics
that are
pressing and urgent in each one of these
domains
so we have these programs
on cancer biology precision medicine
spaceomics and and many others and we're
excited to
share with you that you know these types
of programs have already impacted
hundreds of students in louisiana
thousands of students around the world
and we're hoping that many more across
the national association of idea
principal investigator network as we are
completing our first pilot which um uh
lasted from january until the end of
march so until yesterday
so with that um i am going to be
available to answer any questions uh if
anyone had
any questions
i'm going to share my email address if
you would like to reach out to me
i'd love to talk to you about these
programs i've shared my email in the
chat
we will have a few more speakers from
nepy
speaking about
different efforts that we are going to
kind of combine into this program as
well
and uh i thoroughly enjoyed uh seeing
some of the results that
we have seen and i think that is really
the demonstration of what we are trying
to do some of the research projects that
we've seen from the students
so thank you again
definitely okay thank you very much of
course well that was again a great talk
by dr truble